simply by virtue of being on a college
campus you have at your fingertips
the thing that Foust sold his soul for
which is knowledge and yet students are
encouraged to think of themselves as
victims
here we are on the Sunday special with
Heather McDonald and I cannot wait to
ask her about her new book the diversity
delusion we're gonna talk about the me2
movement we're gonna talk about racial
diversity on campus the quest for
diversity will talk about policing and
crime all sorts of great topics with
Heather McDonald but first let's talk
about what smart figuring out who you
need to hire to take your business to
the next level in 2019 I mean I look
around my staff and most of them are
pretty good but there are a few phases
you know you could upgrade that's why
we're looking at zip recruiters start
the year off strong by going to zip
recruit comm slash been guest to hire
the right people
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
finds qualified candidates just for you
it's powerful matching technology scans
thousands of resumes and identifies
people with the right skills education
and experience and then actively invites
them to apply to your job so you get
qualified candidates fast
that's why zip recruiter is rated number
one by employers in the United States
this rating comes from hiring sites on
trust pilots with over a thousand
reviews right now my listeners can get
to try zip recruiter for free at this
exclusive web addresses zip recruiters
comm slash been guest because I am Ben
and I have a guest
zip recruiter comm slash been guest and
if you love the show show your support
for the show and zip recruiter by going
to zip recruiter comm slash then guess
be Eng you est again zip recruit comm /
Ben guess if we're is the smartest way
to hire go check it out right now zip
recruit comm / Ben Gaza Heather thank
you so much for stopping by I really
appreciate it my rear female guests on
the Sunday special we get so much mail
about it I wonder why that is I know
could it be there's a difference between
males and females or I'm a sexist so
let's talk about your book the diversity
delusion so first of all why should
anybody care about college campuses I
mean what I hear from a lot of
conservatives is that basically college
campuses are placed for the fringe
people get out of college and then they
are ensconced in the real world they
have to pay taxes they have to be
integrated into society and gradually
they become more conservative so why are
we wasting all this breath worrying
about race and gender pandering at the
university level because we're all in
gender studies 101 now it does not stay
put if anything should have told us this
it was the Brett Kavanaugh hearings
where you had a direct transmission belt
from academic rape culture nonsense into
the Senate Judiciary Committee this is
very scary stuff
the whole belief survivors mantra
was put out there with a hashtag during
Brett Kavanaugh that is the identical
travesty destroying due process
destroying the presumption of innocence
that now reigns supreme on college
campuses white males basically are under
a death sentence in this culture today
there's not a single mainstream
institution that is not using radical
race and gender quotas to hire again
this is something that comes out of the
identity politics of the university it
is transforming our world I'm very
familiar with that argument that oh the
market will take care of it and michael
barone a wonderful Washington journalist
wrote a whole book about that that
seemed plausible at the time that
they're soft America which is the
universities in heart America which is
the rigor of the marketplace and that
all these black Studies majors and
Women's Studies majors would just have
to grow a backbone as soon as they got
out unfortunately
that prediction has not hold true it's
it's the universities that are remaking
the academic world in their image well a
lot of folks on the Left would would
sort of counter this by saying that you
know not only does white privilege
exists not only do white people have a
long history of dominating politics in
the United States but the statement that
for example white men are under serious
assault in the culture that that's
overstated white men are still doing
generally okay white men still earn
pretty well and by the way white men
have a long history of dominating a lot
of institutions in the United States so
isn't it time for them to take a back
seat how do you respond to that no the
only thing that should matter is merit
at I don't care what happened in the
past there is no way that lowering your
meritocratic standards in order to
compensate for real or perceived and
phantom racism or sexism in the past
does us any good today and it's simply
not the case today that white males are
dominant there again there's not a
single mainstream institution whether
it's the media that is not twisting
itself into knots for diversity for
running by lines by diverse names
content publishing houses are
scrutinizing they're publishing
lists to engineer diversity of you
basically as a white male you have to be
something we heard about for blacks and
the nineties you have to be twice as
good to get looked at
and this is quite explicit you know you
have corporations signing on to these
pledges to be 50/50 female by 2020 and
they mean it this is this is something
that is very real and is transforming
our culture or one of the complaints
that you hear about the meritocracy and
this is not just a complaint that I
think exists on the Left it's now I
think infected parts of the populace
right is the argument that meritocracy
is itself a sort of tract system that
basically the society is going to break
up into the people who have intellectual
merit and it's gonna leave everybody
else behind and the cure for that is
sort of these force diversity systems
taking into account other other factors
other than merit in a particular field
because if we have a meritocracy then
the people who are the best of things
are the only people who are going to
succeed what do we do with the folks who
are not succeeding in a meritocracy
whatever their race and and gender well
how about we get rid of the ridiculous
idea that everybody should go to college
and that the only way you can have
dignity in life is to have some white
collar job that you've eked out after
getting your communications or marketing
major which is a completely bogus I goal
for a university they should be not
involved in that type of very nuts and
bolts vocational work there is honor and
virtue and accomplishment in working
with your hands in keeping our society
going in in making things but we have
this insane idea where we only valorize
jobs that purport to require a college
degree so I think you know there is some
problem I'm not necessarily a utopian
when it comes to robots I think there's
a problem there leaving aside though
whether technology will cause some major
dislocation we're less cognitively
demanding jobs are really moved into
automation I still think that there's
plenty of things for people to do that
don't require a Google level you know in
intellect ok so let's talk a little bit
about the ideas that are being pushed on
campus you talk about them at length and
the diversity delusion
let's talk about some of the buzzword so
the me2 movement obviously has gained
enormous amounts of steam not just on
the college campuses but also in the
broad mainstream culture you talk in the
book and and more generally about the
inherent contradictions of the meets you
movement what's wrong with the me2
movement well because it has now
devolved into a quota system if this
would stayed put to simply be okay we're
going to take out the most egregious
sexual harasser z' that's perfectly
legitimate because there are some guys
that are exploiting their workplace
power that have lost any sense of male
chivalry thanks to the sexual liberation
and you have absurdities like like louis
c.k masturbating in front of females
this is something that was really
unthinkable I think in the 1950s if that
was its only goal that would be fine but
it is immediately morphed into a system
of spoils so that again you have
Hollywood pledging for a certain amount
of females in directing and in writing
script writing which I love because to
the extent that Hollywood casts its side
it's it's ruthless box-office judgment
for the sake of diversity I love that
Hollywood moguls are not going to be
able to pull in the billion dollar bucks
that allow them to fly across the world
and their private jets while proclaiming
the need for climate change
you know carbon taxes but other are
there areas that are also in the wake of
the me2 quota insanity that should worry
us are things like the science fields
the so-called STEM fields science
technology engineering and math which
have now wedded themselves to the idea
that the only allowable explanation for
the lack of 50/50 gender parity in a
theoretical physics lab or a a computer
engineering department is sexism and
discrimination and that is simply false
I mean this is the one of the things
that absolutely drives me up a wall is
the assumption on the part of folks who
are on the left that if there is any
sort of disparity this is clearly due to
discrimination if there's a disparity
between men and women in the STEM fields
it's due to discrimination even when you
have countries in the Nordic States
where the amount of focus that's been
put on gender disparity is enormous and
the stem
despairities actually growing these it
turns out that women don't want to join
into stem industries in the same way
that men want to join into stem
industries and this goes to a lot of the
stuff that you talk about in your book
and more generally which is a cultural
assumption that we've all made now that
whenever there is a disparity it is due
to discrimination and therefore we have
to do something about the discrimination
by changing the underlying policy and
that I don't want to preemptively gets
it to your positions on crime but this
is sort of the argument that you've made
in the past about criminal law
disparities and so I want to get a
broader take on criminal justice reform
obviously they become a hot issue on the
right and the left the Trump
administration passed a form of criminal
justice reform I first wanted to get
your general take on what that criminal
justice reform system was whether that
was a good idea or a bad idea
well this recent law you're talking
about the first step back to be honest
been I'm agnostic about it because I
think that all sentences are arbitrary
it's not as if there's a Platonic ideal
for dealing meth or dealing crack and
the fact of the matter is politically
it's very hard to ever ratchet down a
sentence you can ratchet them up but if
the penalties had been set at a lower
level to begin with which they've now
been tweaked a little bit in the federal
system nobody would be raising a hue and
cry so unlike some of my fellow
conservatives that did see this as the
end of the world I don't necessarily
what I object to the most about it is
the narrative behind these criminal
justice reform efforts which is the meme
of mass incarceration which is itself a
stand-in for the idea that the fact
which is indisputable that blacks are
over-represented in prison is a result
of racism rather than criminal offending
so to the extent that the whole recent
criminal justice reform push serve to
somehow legitimate that narrative
I think it's worrisome but the actual
little changes that were made in the
federal prison system and I hope my good
sources that are the former federal US
attorneys aren't listening because they
do think it's a big problem I I think we
can probably live with it ok so what the
meme of mass incarceration you you've
spent a lot of time debunking it why do
you think that that's not true it's
become obviously a very popular talking
point there's so many millions
people who are who are in prison er have
been in prison in the last 20 years
proportionally speaking more people in
prison in the United States than in in
European countries why do you think it
is that there are so many people in
prison in the United States as opposed
to other countries because we have a lot
of crime here where a very violent
Society our murder rate is about 22
times higher than in Germany this is we
have violence that is unknown in the
rest of the developing world it's mostly
gun violence but now you know Britain is
sort of trying to catch up with gun with
knife violence but nevertheless with the
degree of family breakdown we have but
it's we've always been a more violent
society as you say I would say that the
moral outrage for the progressive left
at this point is any lack of
proportionality and the the flipside of
that is the refusal to talk about
behavior as well as preferences and
skills and aptitudes but when it comes
to the criminal justice system when it
comes to policing there is a complete
taboo in talking about racial crime
rates which is the one thing that
explains the disparities in the prison
population and when people ask you about
this typically it's it's guised in the
form of you're racist for even
mentioning any of this stuff if you
suggest that the crime rate in the black
community is higher than it is in other
communities in the United States
particularly violent crime then that
obviously is an indicator they that
you're racist because you agree with the
racist cops or rounding up black people
sort of randomly you got a lot of that
during the Obama administration you've
been getting a lot the same amount of
that under the trump administration no
because we're all in the resistance the
meet is in resistance mode and so the
black lives matter narrative has had
less purchase it's just the media has
all of its attention now on impeachment
and trying to take Trump down so the
Obama years were different you know you
had somebody in the White House who was
a very forceful and repetitive exponent
of the black lives matter narrative of
systemic criminal justice racism that
has been removed fortunately former
attorney general Jeff Sessions was quite
explicit about his support for the cops
so
you know I it hasn't been as much I also
haven't been writing about policing
quite as much I've been focusing on the
universities but but in any case we've
sort of moved on you know what I would
say to people that say oh it's racist to
talk about the black homicide rate which
is about eight times higher than whites
and Hispanics combined if you were to
take Hispanics out of that you get about
11 to 12 just rate disparity between
blacks and whites well let's talk about
the criminal victimization rate this is
the civil rights violation of our time
that blacks die of homicide at six times
the rate of whites and Hispanics
combined I don't see any black lives
matter activists protesting that but
that is a major major disparity the the
full phenomenon of getting gunned down
in a drive-by shooting that does not
happen to white kids if it did there
would be a revolution in this country in
2016 there were 4,300 people shot in
Chicago that's one person every two
hours they were all black can you
imagine if 4,300 white people had been
shot it's unthinkable the media doesn't
give a damn about black bodies unless
they're shot by a cop they do give a
damn about white bodies we see what
happens if there's a school shooting you
know when white kids are taken out it's
the end of the world there is a school
shooting type experience every couple of
months in the black community and nobody
gives a damn about it except the police
and the families of those kids that are
shot so in a second I want to ask you to
mythbuster little bit all of the focus
on drug crime because of the one of the
ideas that's been put out there about
crime is that the disproportionate
number of people in prison is
specifically because of the war on drugs
and if we got rid of the war on drugs
then it would alleviate this problem but
before we get to that I first want to
talk to you about getting a life
insurance you need to get life insurance
okay you're an adult stop being a child
it's time for you to recognize something
you're gonna die okay we all know it I
know it you know it everybody knows it
you're gonna die and that means that you
need life insurance cuz when you plotz
you don't want your Pam your family
taking your body and shoving you into a
pauper's grave like Mozart at the end of
instead go get some life insurance all
you have to do is head on over to policy
genius it's hard to know where to start
but making sure your family's
financially protected is really
important policy genius has created a
website that makes it easy for you to
compare quotes get advice get covered
without extra fees or Commission sales
agents policy genius is the easy way to
get life insurance in minutes you can
compare quotes from top insurers to find
the coverage you need at a price you can
afford from there you can apply online
the advisors of policy genius will
handle all the red tape then we even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company it's all part of their best
price guarantee and policy genius
doesn't just do life insurance they also
do disability insurance to protect your
income and homeowners insurance and auto
insurance they can help you get covered
fast so if you've been intimidated or
frustrated by insurance in the past try
starting your search of policy genius
calm in minutes
comparequotes you can do the whole thing
on your phone right now policy genius it
is indeed the easy way to compare and
buy life insurance ok so let's talk a
little bit about drug decriminalization
yeah I'm in favor of decriminalization
of marijuana I've heard arguments on
both sides of that particular issue but
I'm in favor of that because it seems to
me that the war on drugs has been a
giant fail in a lot of ways particularly
with regard to marijuana when I was in
Middle School people were dealing
marijuana on the playground and it
wasn't hard to get so it seems to me
that the law enforcement community just
has been unable to control the problem
there's just too much of a market for it
where do you come down on drug
criminalization and also where do you
come down on the argument that the vast
disparity with regard to people in
prison these so-called problem of mass
incarceration that that's the result of
the war on drugs specifically well let
me take the second question first which
is something that I've got empirical
evidence for the other is really a
hypothesis and an experiment that we're
living through right now which is what
would happen if we decriminalize or
legalize completely as far as the
argument that the prison population in
the u.s. is driven by the so-called war
on drugs it's preposterous this BS it's
a way of getting people all riled up
against incarceration if I can run some
numbers by you the state prison
population is our largest prison system
it's eighty eight percent of all
prisoners sixteen percent of all state
prisoners are there for a drug crime of
which twelve percent are for possession
I'm sorry twelve percent are for
trafficking four percent for precession
those possession
four percent of the entire state prison
population have virtually all been pled
down from trafficking
nobody virtually zero of our of our
prison population is therefore smoking a
joint or even possessing joint amount of
marijuana the reason people are in
prison overwhelmingly is violent crime
and property crime in the federal system
about 50 percent are there for drug
crimes but it's a again 12% of the
population generally there's about a
hundred and sixteen federal prisoners
who are there for marijuana trafficking
and the other typical chestnut that we
get from the black lives matter
anti-mass incarceration movement is the
federal crack penalties that these are
also responsible for the blacks in
federal prison well guess who wanted
very high stiff penalties on crack it
was the Congressional Black Caucus who
said that the crack epidemic was the
worst oppression that their community
and experience in slavery these are
people like Charles Rangel alton maddox
in in brooklyn the the federal crack
penalties before they were revised are
identical to the federal meth penalties
identical mandatory five-year sentence
for an X amount of meth or crack
well meth is dealt overwhelmingly by
whites about two percent of meth
traffickers are black so if the crack
penalties are anti black then the meth
penalties are anti white but nobody
complaints about those so I want to get
back to the college campuses in just a
minute first I need to ask you a little
bit about illegal immigration because
you've written pretty extensively about
illegal immigration and one of the
things that you've said for example is
that the illegal immigration problem
isn't gonna stop until employers stop
the illegal immigration problem that
basically e-verify is the solution to
legal immigration as wonder if you could
expand on the next night we may have a
slight disagreement on that actually
well I don't think it's the only
solution
I'm actually not against a wall but I do
think that you do have to try and dry up
the jobs
it's a mixed metaphor but butt-end the
fact that a lot of people do come into
the country illegally because they think
they can get work they're driving wages
down in this country mass low-skilled
immigration whether it's legal or
illegal hurts low-skilled Americans most
of all it drags their wages down so I
think it's perfectly reasonable to ask
employers to make sure that they are
verifying that the documents that are
presented to them are actually valid I'm
curious why you're against yes sir I
mean I I abide by the law when it comes
to this sort of stuff I remember there
was a we went through it an agency to
try and find our current nanny and
before they banned we said this person
needs to be a citizen they brought us a
person who was pretty good we asked for
her social security number she wasn't a
citizen we paid her for her time and
coming to see us but then we said we
can't hire you obviously and I mean
number one I'm not a feelings guy but it
didn't feel great to tell somebody that
they couldn't be hired because of all
this but put put aside the feelings as I
say I don't really care very much about
that my basic problem is the idea that
employers are supposed to enforce the
law when the feds won't meaning that if
I were to find an illegal immigrant in
our community and drive that person over
to ice I would be arrested for
kidnapping right but I'm supposed to
enforce the law when it comes to
immigration in a way that the federal
government and state government of the
state of California will not hear the
state government of California will not
even report it to the feds if somebody
is arrested and is an illegal immigrant
in the state system so we don't even
have good statistics on that and yet I
is an employer will be arrested if I had
not end up in prison in illegal
immigrant if I put in an illegal
immigrant on my payroll then I as an
employer will be penalized for this it
seems to me that there's nothing deeply
immoral about me hiring a person who
wants to work for a wage but there is
something immoral about the federal
government forcing me to enforce the law
in a way the federal government will not
itself enforce the law well yeah number
one you verify has a safe harbor
provision so that if you use the system
and it turns out right that somehow
somebody got through you are not going
to jail so I just don't think that it's
either/or I think it's both and I think
that you do have to make sure that
people cannot get through the system and
get a job
but obviously sanctuary cities are an
absolute abomination I don't know of any
other
of law enforcement where you have
different aspects of it refusing to
cooperate otherwise it's sort of a
seamless web it should be that way I
mean we learned after 9/11 that one of
the problems was this wall between the
CIA and FBI and local law enforcement
who got rid of that for for local law
enforcement to thumb their nose at
federal immigration enforcement officers
say you're not allowed into my Jail is
just it's a travesty so obviously we
need to get rid of sanctuary cities and
Jeff Sessions was trying to do so and
was getting blocked of course by by
every federal judge that that this came
up against except maybe in Texas but but
I just I don't think it's not burdensome
it's an instantaneous thing to be able
to check-in employers and employees I
mean I also say openly I am libertarian
when it comes to the flavor so I don't
have any problem with people coming as
guest workers into the country and
working I don't have a problem with h-1b
visas I have no problem with people
coming in and filling jobs that
employers want to pay them for
businesses will offshore if they are not
allowed to do this in price is lower
because of lower wages so well it does
there's no question that a higher supply
of Labor lowers wages in particular
areas of the economy but frankly so it
sort of is sort of my answer to that
that's that is the libertarian answer to
my Calot snowboarders absolutely a
flavor when it comes to when it comes to
safety when it comes to welfare yes
borders right so I want to make sure
that people who are coming in the
country this is why I'm for a wall this
is why I am for criminal background
checks on people coming into the country
this is why I don't believe that people
should be given citizenship unless they
are found to be of net benefit to the
United States but people who are coming
in to work and then leaving again or
sending the money home or something and
not on welfare I don't really have any
problem with that whatsoever it's it's
it's an interesting kind of difference
between what I would term sort of the
the more populist wing of the Republican
Party and the libertarian wing I've had
this conversation with Ann Coulter
actually about her book because she was
deeply concerned about undercutting the
wage base with regard to immigration I
was concerned more about crime and
welfare dependency among people who are
coming into the country I'm not sure
where you stand on that well first of
all I don't think the idea that well
you're all for importing labor but not
for other
is a valid distinction because you don't
just import a worker you import a
culture you import a family you import a
entire way of being in the world and I
think what I see I've spent a lot of
time in high Hispanic neighborhoods in
California around Santa Ana and Orange
County East LA and yes on the one hand
they've had an incredible effect on say
South Central Los Angeles because
there's more entrepreneurship in those
areas than there was before on the other
hand what I've seen is a migration of
many second and third-generation
Hispanics into creating a second
underclass you have the highest school
dropout rate in the country the highest
teen pregnancy rate among Hispanics and
so there's wonderful success stories of
people moving up but it is happening
very slowly and there is high welfare
use obviously you would say well let's
let's enforce the rule against becoming
a public charge yes let's do that but so
far that's been very hard to do so I I
guess I think that immigration is simply
should be in the interests of a country
but that is not excluded exclusively
about the cheapest wages but what sort
of culture do we want to be I mean I
generally agree that contention I think
that a better example of and it may be a
little clarifying example is where you
are on for example h-1b visas so I know
that that both an and people like Tom
cotton Jeff Sessions very much against
the the use of h-1b visas because they
feel that that's depressing wages even
in high wage industries the use of h-1b
visas there I don't have much of a
problem
I don't really have any problem at all
frankly I have a personal stake in the
matter my father the most here on an
h-1b visa before getting a before
becoming a citizen of the United States
and obviously my wife is a citizen of
the United States where are you on h-1b
s yeah frankly I'm gonna punt on that
because I haven't really uh I'm I'm
influenced by people like Mark Krikorian
of the center of Immigration Studies who
I respect enormous Lee who do say that
it's without your father of me
immanuel I don't let in personal stories
yeah but you know that this is in fact
they just are going for the lowest
common denominator and that there is no
shortage of American labor for you know
low-level computer inputting jobs or
something so I don't know on the other
hand I'm also very open to the argument
that I've heard from my libertarian
friends who were former business owners
that it's not about low wages we want
work skills and that I'm completely
sympathetic to it is undeniably the case
that a lot of Americans have lost a
really reliable work ethic and a lot of
immigrants do have that so you know and
and we all are bargain hunters we're
seem to be wired for wanting the
cheapest thing and so a lot of us are
complicit in this of wanting cheaper
goods cheaper services so it's a very
tough problem but I guess I would say on
the whole I think that we need to slow
down the rate of demographic change and
I know this is getting a lot of
conservative media hosts in a lot of
trouble for saying things like that but
I think that a pause is necessary for
simulation and just to see you know how
things are playing out because we've had
some very very radical massive
population flows recently and it's not
clear to me when you combine this with
our ethic of anti assimilation how this
is going to work out or is working out
because I think we're already seeing
some problems of that where you have
even very high-skilled immigrants like
Asians adopting the oppositional
mentality of a victim ideology which is
incredibly perverse let's talk a little
bit about the the demographic change
argument before we get ourselves
boycotted because I think that what you
mean by that is actually not what some
folks on the Left would suggest I mean
by that what they what they think you
mean by that is that we need more white
people and fewer brown people right that
was the way they would put it on MSNBC
is that when you say demographic change
what you're deeply worried about is too
many black and brown people and not
enough white people and it seems to me
that the argument whether it's made by
Tucker Carlson or by you or by Ann
Coulter for that matter with regard to
this particular issue has not really
been a color based argument it's been
culture based meaning that if somebody
wants to come in and assimilate to
American values I don't care what color
they are I don't really care what
religion they are what you know what
shoulr or mosque or church they go to
what I care about is them assimilating
to basic American values including
values of community including values of
free speech and free enterprise and non
dependency and if you're willing to
assimilate and learn English the way
that everybody else's great-grandparents
did three generations ago my
great-grandparents Ted then that's
totally fine then come on in but the
problem is that we have had this
multicultural ethos that has really
helped fragment and destroy the culture
overall right we are teaching people to
hate I completely agree cultures what
matters bourgeois habits of deferred
gratification self-control a sense of
public space not littering you know
cleaning up around your house those
things really matter I think Americans
and this sounds you know I'll be
criticized for being incredibly naive we
are so ready to be post-racial if only
the damn diversity bureaucrats would get
out of the K through 12 schools get out
of the pre-k schools where they are
trying to it's amazing I mean I was
talking to somebody who has a child in a
gifted and talented school here in LA up
in Mulholland Drive they are now
starting to do affinity group training
for the youngest elementary school so
that kids can start developing their
tribal group identity as an early
possible age and so if people came with
a sense of my goal here is to become
American nobody would give a damn
but you also see still cultural habits
that are not the same forward-looking
entrepreneurship in some of the groups
are bringing in and and that's a problem
okay so let's talk in a second about
this multicultural ethos the diversity
ethos we talked about in your book first
let's talk about brushing your teeth so
the new year means new resolutions we've
got one that you are working on twice
every day it's your oral health and with
equip electric toothbrush sticking to
good habits is simple I know you lie to
the dentist you say you brush regularly
you say you brush for the proper amount
of time stop lying to yourself instead
you ought to get equipped toothbrush the
guiding features are like a built-in
support system for
brushing sensitive sonic vibrations for
an effective clean that is gentle on
your sensitive gums built-in two-minute
timer pulses every 30 seconds to remind
you when to switch sides and help you
clean your whole mouth evenly brush
heads delivered on a dentist recommended
schedule every three months for just
five bucks so you're not gonna be
brushing with that same old brush head
that your child may or may not have used
to clean the toilet a friendly reminder
when it's time for a refresh and to stay
committed to your oral health quip is
one of the first electric toothbrushes
accepted by the American Dental
Association they are backed by over 25
thousand dental professionals they have
thousands of verified five-star reviews
I love my quip electric toothbrush I use
it twice a day for these pearly whites
and I use them two minutes a day it is
just fantastic whip starts with just $25
if you go to get quip comm slash been
guest right now you can get your first
refill pack for free again get your
first refill pack for free at GE t qu IP
comm slash been guest that is get quip
comm slash been guest okay so let's talk
a little about the multi cultural ethos
because that really is at the heart of
the diversity delusion it's the title of
the book what our college is getting
wrong about diversity well they define
it by the trivialities of gonads and
melanin and now all the various gender
identities they're being rapidly crafted
by desperate students who have finding
it's getting harder and harder to be
transgressive and get your own personal
bureaucracy to cater to your delusions
about being oppressed frankly I think
diversity comes naturally I don't I
think any individual is diverse but I
don't even think it should be a goal in
any in any sense even intellectual
diversity if we didn't have such a
monolithic I I think I would excise the
word completely I would not put in good
diversity versus the the preposterous
narrow narcissistic diversity is
currently defined I think the goal of
university should be knowledge pure and
simple and a gratitude for the greatness
of the past for the works of sublime
creation that it is our privilege to
have inherited so you know but but now
diversity is just a code word for a
whole set of things primarily what you
meant
before bin which is this idea that any
lack of proportional representation is
by definition a signal that somewhere
someplace or everywhere is lethal
discrimination and it is also the
diversity ideology is giving students a
ground to be completely out of touch
with reality
it's just it's remarkable the reigning
view is that to be a female or a
so-called student of color on an
American College campus today is to be
at literal threat to your life from
circumambulation and sexism this is not
hyperbole students really believe it you
know the students occupied the
president's office at Brown complaining
about the fact that they had to follow
such quotidian academic expectations as
going to class or studying for exams
because they said they were focused so
hard on quote staying alive at Brown now
there is no more privileged place in
human history than a college campus I
don't care if you're purple green or
blue or if you come from a family of
twenty five thousand dollars a year or
two million dollars a year simply by
virtue of being on a college campus you
have at your fingertips
the thing that Foust sold his soul for
which is knowledge every intellectual
resource is open to you without regards
to your color or your gender every book
that has ever been written you can read
this is something that would have driven
the Renaissance humanists mad with envy
and desire and yet students are
encouraged by their presidents by the
metastasizing sprawling multi-million
dollar diversity of bureaucracy to think
of themselves as victims where'd all
this get started because if you look at
the history of the university supposedly
it was supposed to be what you're
talking about you're bringing knowledge
trying to study eternal truths looking
at the universe around you and now it's
a competitive Olympics of victimhood
how did that get started and who's
interested in promulgating this well I
think it started in the 60s when you had
civil rights movements morphing into
black power and schools that for
completely understandable reasons said
boy we've got to quickly jumpstart a
black student body and employed the same
technique that they're employing today
which is incredibly self-destructive and
counterproductive which is vast racial
preferences bringing students in who do
not share the average academic skills of
their peers in order to fulfill a racial
quota and students that are brought in
under any type of preference it could be
a gender preference whatever who are not
competitively qualified are going to
struggle so you had the creation of
Black Studies majors ethnic studies
majors to try and give something to
these preference beneficiaries that
would that they could succeed at and
then you had the rise of high theory
which is something initially quite
remote this was deconstruction
post-structuralism which were very
arcane and very bizarre theories about
language that I unfortunately wasted my
college years absorbing uncritically
without any sense of skepticism towards
them but they still read the canon and
and so even though I was reading Jacques
de edad to my eternal dig regret I was
also reading Wordsworth and edmund
spenser
and John Milton and wallowing in
language of just exquisite beauty in the
80s some of the core ideas of
deconstruction took a 180 degree turn
deconstruction had denied that there was
such a thing as a human self a
completely counterfactual proposition
but nevertheless one that lured in
stupid students like me the weird thing
is that deconstruction in the 80s some
of their ideas turned into this roaring
revival of the self so now it's all
about me
narcissism as a female I'm supposed to
only want to study female writers or I
want to read books to get a sense of how
oppressed females were in the past this
is an just a a travesty of what
education should be which is about
taking our own petty selves out of
ourselves into a world that is so much
larger than our minds could ever have
encompassed and instead students only
want to study their sexuality their
sexual preferences and again they're
being encouraged by this in this by
their by their faculty so let me give
the counter Eggman's the counter
argument for the sake of playing devil's
advocate for a lot of folks on the left
is that the the prevailing theory of
America and of the West had been that it
is a great and glorious place filled
with great discoveries and Freedoms and
prosperity but that prosperity and
freedom has been built on the backs of a
lot of different various victimized
subgroups over the course of history and
their plates have been ignored and that
it is incumbent on us now that we have
reached beyond the the point of Western
civilization alone to look at all these
various subgroups and recognize that
they have been intersectionally
victimized and we can judge them by
their intersectional categories if
you're a member of several categories
then you've been victimized in a variety
of ways this means that you have an
experience that no one else can
understand because you yourself have
been a member of these particular groups
and your subjective membership in any of
these groups means that we all have to
judge you that way and if we fail to
judge you that way then we are simply
standing in for the patriarchal
oppressive system above is that
completely wrong seventy percent wrong
what what percentage wrong is that when
it comes to building a better world well
we have not been at risk for a sort of a
nationalist self glorifying narrative
about our past for quite some time now I
don't think there's any dearth of our
history books or our history courses
papering over the very real very
unfathomable hypocrisy z' that dominated
America for instance for nearly 200
years with our stunning blonde
- to the fact that both slavery and de
jure segregation were just blatant
violations of what this nation purported
to stand for and it's always just
amazing to see the patience the
patriotism the courage with which the
civil rights pioneers were willing to
keep fighting to get America to live up
to its ideals but the idea that now
we're still living in this world that is
blind to the failures of the West I
think is completely counterfactual and
it it is the case I would also say
what's empirically demonstrably wrong is
the idea that the West is today the font
of all evil if you want to see a
patriarchy you know go to rural Nepal
where girls who are having their periods
forced to stay in a hut because they're
so impurity homophobia trying house
trying sponsor a gay pride march in
Uganda Egypt it recently imprisoned
people at a rock concert who had
unfurled a rainbow banner in solidarity
with the lead singer of a rock band who
was gay and they're considering
criminalizing homosexuality the rest of
the world the non-western world every
single day is trying to come to the west
whether legally or illegally why are
they deluded are they deluded about the
fact that coming to this place of a
vicious racism and sexism will oppress
them or do they realize that at this
point there has never been a freer more
tolerant opportunity filled Society in
human history and this is a cliche among
conservatives but it I guess it bears
repeating that there's hardly a culture
in the world that has not practiced
slavery including Africa but the West
was the the society that developed the
abstract ideals
of a humanity that transcended tribal
identities that paved the way for
outlawing slavery
it didn't happen elsewhere it happened
in the West because of the Enlightenment
and the evolution of ideas of fairness
due process and a universal humanity now
for saying all this stuff obviously are
very threatening person I mean I know
that you know you sound very threatening
you're very scary human that's saying
well they're both protesting at college
campuses I feel sort of bad I always
mention your name when people talk about
protests at college campus cuz I get all
sorts of attention for going to Berkeley
with six hundred police officers but
you've been physically accosted at
places like Claremont McKenna can you
talk a little bit about your experiences
on college campuses
well Claremont was definitely the nadir
of Yahoo's students that were out there
to try and feel like they had some you
know social justice mission to feel
important I was there to speak about my
previous book the war on cops and to
bring the message that there are many
law-abiding residents of high crime
neighborhoods who love the police you
know I cannot go to a police community
meeting in South LA or East Harlem where
I don't hear we want the cops please get
the drug dealers off the street with all
apologies to the war on drugs but people
feel this is an oppression and so for
that first saying that there are people
who support the cops in inner-city
communities and that there's no
government agency more dedicated to the
proposition that black lives matter than
the police because they save tens of
thousands of minority lives starting in
the 1990s through proactive policing I
was declared a homophobe racist classist
anti female you know a colonialist you
name it
by the students at the colleges around
Claremont McKenna which is a small
liberal arts college in east of Los
Angeles
they blockaded the auditorium where I
was supposed to speak so that no
students could come in here me enter I
was taken in through a with a police
escort through a secret passageway and
spoke to an empty room outside the
students were pound
the windows and and chanting and
drumming and the police eventually
decided then these were large plate
glass windows that they couldn't
guarantee my safety so I was escorted
out but you know these are students that
have never had to live with real high
crime they don't know a thing and it was
something you know one can hear about
the free speech crisis from afar but to
be at the center of a mob is is a
sobering experience because you don't
know what they're going to do next and
to just feel that feral confidence in
their own rectitude and their
willingness to exercise the tool of
every oppressive fascist government in
human history which is to be the
arbiters of acceptable expression is is
really something so let's talk a little
bit about the perceived threats on
campus so you're perceived as a threat
I'm perceived as a threat we both get
I'm sure all sorts of posters about how
threatening and terrible we are so this
is where the buzzwords come in right the
buzzwords come in when when people feel
threatened so rape culture right you've
been accused of promoting rape culture
I've been accused of promoting rape
culture what the hell is rape culture
I'm just honestly I do not even have a
good definition for what people mean
when they say rape culture because I'm
unaware of the constituency that is
radically in favor of rape in the United
States what exactly am I missing here
what do they mean by this and why are
they wrong well I guess they would say
the very fact that we have rape at all
means that we're in a rape culture that
somehow we are indifferent to or
tolerant of or even encouraging of
females getting raped or that maybe to
be a little less hyperbolic they would
say that the patriarchy so strong we so
devalue females lives that it results in
a acceptance towards male violence but
you're right I mean I've never really
tried to pin it down myself and I'm I'm
struggling here a little bit been
because it is a extraordinarily broad
term but I guess to just sort of give
them the benefit of the doubt it's
shorthand for we still live in a culture
that devalues females lives and and sees
them as sex objects and in the
contention is that by even talking about
the fact that women are free in the
United States the freest women in human
history actually in the most prosperous
women in human history that this is
actually a threat to women that if you
talk about the prosperity of women how
women ought to do well that this is a
threat to women because we need to
recognize their inherent victim status
otherwise we are ignoring their their
cruel plight yeah well it's ridiculous
everybody wants to be a victim today
I've recently learned that white males
in their desperate sort of affinity
group circles where everybody's going to
trade victim points and see where they
end up on the intersectional totem pole
have taken to saying well I think I'm on
the spectrum because you know this gives
them some opportunity to themselves not
be strong it's a very weird
civilizational development because for
centuries for like all of human history
cultures wanted to celebrate strength
and accomplishment and success and now
we celebrate alleged victim hood and
oppression it's a it's a bizarre
reversal of how how societies used to
run themselves and you know one
explanation is possibly Nietzsche said
that Christianity was a major sort of
betrayal of classical ideals and that it
celebrated the original victim and
whether that's going on that somehow in
a secular way that idea of a skepticism
towards strength and a glorification of
weakness is going on but for females
today to think of themselves as
oppressed is ridiculous again we don't
want to personalize this and the one
needs a balance between anecdotes and
data but I can just tell you that I have
never been discriminated against in my
life I was in college in the 70s my
school had recently gone co-ed if ever
there would have been a time when the
faculty was hostile towards females why
did they bring them in you know they
were destroying standards or whatever it
would have been then I I had enormous
support from my from my professors and
ever since then I have without a doubt
been the alleged beneficiary of gender
quotas constantly constantly I mean
every every panel every media experience
is desperate for females so for any
especially you know well I don't want to
get intersectional myself but for a
white female to claim that she's
oppressed is particularly ludicrous and
that doesn't mean that I'm granting any
legitimacy to the well speaking as a
black female meme because I think that
just all of these all of these little
identity markers are irrelevant but but
nevertheless the female narcissistic
whining is particularly nauseating to me
well it seems like the combination of
the death of the notion of objective
truth the death of the notion of the
idea of eternal truth combined with the
need for victimhood in a society where
victimhood is actually kind of hard to
come by has led people to the bizarre
notion that you are victimized if people
disagree with you that your politics
your views are wrapped up in your
subjective self definition and thus if
people disagree with you they have
attacked our identity you have erased
them as human beings
this obviously comes up most commonly in
the context of transgenderism in the
discussion of transgender pronouns if
you suggest that there's such a thing as
a biological male in a biological female
and that a male cannot become a female
then you are a member of the oppressive
class how would you how would you argue
with that with that sort of thing
transgender specifically or just that
seems to be the hot topic not just
nothing you know not to argue with
transgender folks specifically but the
idea that it is oppression of high order
and serious consequence if somebody says
that males are males and females are
females for example yeah that's a hard
one to unpack I have been sort of on the
margins of the transgender Wars and I've
not had that direct experience that
people like you or Jordan Peterson have
had it's it's so complicated because
they are making so radical a claim about
the irrelevance II of biology and and
their right to choose their own sexual
identity that in refusing to use their
favorite pronouns you are in some sense
striking at their definite
of themselves and and your your relying
on your understanding of science so it's
a tough one that that's sort of the
toughest one that's out there I am much
more confident in being able to say that
empirically we are not mainstream
institutions are not discriminating
against females or people of color how
to navigate that bizarre act of power
that is going on now with transgender
people in trying to put other people in
their linguistic under their linguistic
thrall is is a challenge but in in some
sense when they're saying it's a threat
to their own identity given that that is
how they're choosing to define their
identity there is something at least
semantically plausible about that okay
so in a second I want to ask you one
final question I wanna ask you
specifically as a policy expert who's
focused on campuses and on and on crime
how the Trump administration is doing
across the board on some of these issues
but if you want to hear Heather McDonald
answer you have to be a daily wire
subscriber to subscribe just go over to
daily wire comm click Subscribe and you
can hear the end of our conversation
there well Heather McDonald thank you so
much for stopping by her book is the
diversity delusion if you haven't
checked it out you absolutely should
oliver books a great war on cops as
great diversity delusion is great i'm a
little honest with you when i have a
policy well in case you i don't know the
answer to heather's one of the people
that i turn to have never answered well
thank you so much for stopping by
pleasure
[Music]
eventually row shows Sunday special is
produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Jess wah alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]